hello I'm parka and my talk is called
Wolfram in the mobile world and it
covers three of our main apps well from
alphago from cloud and wool from flare
and we'll be talking about some of the
new upcoming features and how you can
use those apps you Nance you're running
ok good afternoon everyone I hope
everybody had a great lunch and this is
Wolfram in a mobile world and my name is
Pat clap and I work on the desktop and
mobile friends today I'm gonna be
talking to you about three of our apps
welcome player both from alpha and
welcome cloud we'll be going over there
features what new features are coming
and how you can use them to enhance your
learning but before I get started about
talking about them I want to talk about
how I view learning to me learning is a
three-step process where the steps are
discover create and play you really
learn you have to have all these steps
according in my opinion because that's
how I have learned in the past and
discovery is all about finding new
things trying new things out and
developing an intuition for them
intuition being the key part after that
you get to create this is where you get
your hands dirty you break everything
possible just don't break too many
things because you have to fix them
otherwise and the final step is play
this is the most fun step because you've
all done all this work now you actually
get to try it out and all these put
together you get to learn so for me the
discovery process really started on
November 25th 2010 when I first
purchased my first copy of Wolfram Alpha
well it's not the last one I purchased
I've purchased total of five since then
so in a way I've paid my own salary
somehow so
Wolfram Alpha is app that brings the
power of Wolfram Alpha to your mobile
device and it's available on the four
stores another elicitor right there and
in the end I will put up this
presentation with active links so you
can go grab it so let's take a look what
it looks like when you start you're
greeted by this beautiful search bar
where you can type in anything you want
to try so let's take a simple plot which
I was just doing beforehand so plots
sine of X cosine of Y you're seeing the
contour plot of you're seeing the
regular plot but if you wanna see the
contour plot you tap a little button
that says show contour lines there
ah there we go welcome alpha is very
powerful it brings everything your have
come to expect from the website on to
your mobile device we have it for iPad
and I I phones I'm just showing an iPad
today so let's take a look at some of
the features for the Wolfram Alpha you
have the search bar up top you can
search at the bottom you have related
query used to act to what you're trying
so if you want to take a look at
something else you want to do let's say
plot of L enough sine of X cosine of Y
you can try that out if you really like
the query and maybe you want to take a
look at it in future you can favorite it
click on the share menu and add to
favorites and that query has been
favorited which will show up in your
favorites bar oh I guess we found about
that I should fix I'll get somebody to
fix moving along
you also have history you can take a
look at everything you have searched so
let's say you type a big expression in
and you want to come back to in future
we're just gonna do one of those to take
a look in great X e to the negative x
from 0 to infinity you don't want to
type it all in there you go it gives you
the indefinite integral for it you can
come back to it some of the other
features we have a huge number of
examples so let's say you want to try
something out in a category let's try
cultural and media Goodfellas you're
going to find out about Goodfellas you
can click on it and it'll bring up the
information for it what year it came out
who is a director so we have a vast
number of categories you can try and
let's say if you want to learn about
something random click on show a random
example I have no idea what's gonna pull
oh oh
my favorite sales tax yeah so you can
try I've learned it quite a bit a few
new things just doing this so it's
amazing now let's say if you want to if
you're in a results query and you want
to try something else tap on the little
link and for example it's negative 2 to
the 2/3 power you click on it it becomes
a new search player you can try out so
it's like Turtles all the way down you
can keep going going going I've yet to
find a dead end so
crying things well was really powerful
for trying different things math is not
the only thing you can do with it it has
a vast amount of knowledge you can fire
just some of the players actually just
last night somebody was telling me how
they use the get information in movies
search query to find that movie with
Samuel Jackson I forget the who the
other person was in case you're curious
the movie was the King's Men
so I particularly liked the Tommy a joke
it has always resulted in funny ones so
try that point when you get that so my
my office powerful as I've shown but
what about where are we going
what's new what's coming sometimes you
know you're working on a hard problem
you're just stuck as to where you're
going so we're introducing well from
Alpha Pro and mobile so it's the same
Pro you have come to expect from the
website but now it's on mobile and you
have different plans for every group and
we're trying to make it as accessible as
possible you can get Wolfram Alpha Pro
for as little as a coffee mind you it's
a Starbucks coffee not a gas station
coffee so so let's take a look at what
it looks like so this is there you go
you wolf alpha puh so let's do so this
was an integral you can try it now in
the past it would just give you the
indefinite integral as it's in the first
pot up top but let's say you were doing
homework or anything else and you're
stuck at a particular step you can click
on step by step solutions which will
walk you through the problem and how to
solve it so you can do one step at a
time and let's say there are steps in
the intermediate or you can you're stuck
on like how do I get from Step A to B so
we have step eight point one eight point
two eight point three now click on
shrine remediate steps
and voila there are the steps so you
know sometimes you can know all the math
concepts but this little thing you're
just stuck on is happening before and if
you want to look at the whole problem
you just tap on show all steps and it
will walk you through how to do the
problem I think it's a great resource
for finding out like what you don't know
because sometimes a problem can be like
oh I just don't know that one key thing
how to do and you can go ahead and solve
that and this is what I was talking
about developing an intuition once you
do many types of problems you look at
many things there's just like oh that's
the step I needed and over time as you
look at enough problems you start to
develop that intuition so let's try a
few more examples yeah so this is about
finding the extrema of this solution now
you can see their local minimum local
maximum and one global minimum let's say
you're you want to find out how to look
at the local maximum you can tap on step
by step and there you go you can go
through all the steps or one step at a
time and as most students I only
actually ever usable from Alpha on
mobile I've hardly ever used the website
so this is great feature for me yeah
going back now that you've learned how
to like find an intuition for different
problems but what if you want to get
more powerful than that what if you want
to try different things which are like
you want to program a little bit to find
different solutions so that's where the
whole from cloud app comes in as yawn
talk to news talk will from cloud
notebooks are really powerful and well
from cloud that brings the powerful from
cloud notebooks to your mobile devices
so here if you can go ahead and create a
new notebook at the bottom we have the
cell insertion bar you can select a new
cell input cell and you can type in
anything so let's do a plot and we also
offer Auto completions which are shown
at the bottom here let's say you want to
do a regular plot you can tap on
and while we have templates so in case
you forget something as I forget all the
time since I'm a new coder I think it's
more important to remember how to code
rather than remembering the syntax of
what you're writing so this is where it
comes in really hot you tap on the
template and it brings up all the
different plot templates we have so
let's just do a simple plot here make it
a little bigger
we support magnification and there you
go so we're going to tap here X this is
your simple X there we go key wasn't
working X and we're just gonna do X from
10 to 20 and we support tabs so you
never like to lift your finger off to
click through the different template and
you can do shift enter oh wow okay and
then at the bottom we have the
prediction predictive interface you can
try different things out here so let's
do a different one
let's do factorial shift enter so there
you go if you want to find out what that
is in scientific notation click here and
that gives you the scientific notation
so Wolfram cloud really brings the power
of Wolfram cloud notebooks to your
mobile devices it's amazing you can use
it anyplace
it's available on multiple devices some
of the other features we have you can
rename some of the features we have a
full access to your cloud file so you
can do any you can view any of them
let's say if somebody's shared with you
some file these are shared by you and if
somebody shared with you these are all
the files you have been shared with you
so if somebody shares with your file you
can take a look at these we also have
recent so you support full
so let's try a more more powerful
example here let's do an edge detect and
I know what the format is I'm just gonna
use the template to remind myself and
let's do a image insertion hello and
this works so you have the full power of
the cloud running behind as I mentioned
remembering format the format of how you
type code is not as important as knowing
how to code I get stuck all the time in
writing code so we've been working on a
new feature that should help you write
better code by remembering the correct
format so here let's create a new
notebook tap on here so let's say you're
working on a plot 3d and you have
completely forgotten how to do the
notation I don't remember what goes
where so we're adding documentation
sidebar now you tap on here and you'll
have your documentation available as
you're typing so let's look at
visualization graphic I think it's
somebody data make sure this
alliteration aha 3d and there's the
format so you can go ahead I should
bring the cursor back
and there's your plot so also if you
want to try some example here and you're
lazy sometimes and you don't want to
type everything in you can type on the
inputs I'll copy to clipboard and just
go over here and paste and evaluate this
is quite handy as you don't have to type
which I love I love these little
features great you're not required to
type heck I use Siri if I could get
everything to be spoken so now we have
seen how well from cloud notebooks are
powerful so that completes the second
part of our journey of creation but I
think the most important part is playing
so that's where we have her uf which was
released a year ago it's the Wolfram
player and as jason has taught them in
his talk he covered already the most
important features but I will go over in
case somebody didn't attend Jason's talk
so welcome player is running a local
kernel on your iOS device and you get
full interactivity with your content for
the in-app purchase or with a plate paid
cloud account so you can open any
notebook that's on your device which you
can do side loading you can access from
cloud and you get full interactivity
that's a little dizzy you should try
that before and as you can see it's
quite powerful
there's no slowdown whatsoever
here's some more examples so I tried the
same notebook in desktop and the player
is a little bit faster than desktop and
I can say that because I work on both
products so nobody's gonna come after me
here so as you can see it's amazing it's
just like having any content right there
there's nothing in between and that's a
great point like in cloud you have all
the two bells and whistles but with
player is this you and your content
there's nothing else to worry about it
you can do whatever you want to do with
it so here as I mentioned you have your
files on your device you also have cloud
files we support multiple cloud access
so I have three cloud accounts
the left-hand side of my personal
account the accounts we used to test and
we also allow access to your private
clouds so if you want to load up all the
things but don't want to be shared I
costs like public clouds you can add
them here which you do by adding another
cloud account and you have access to
that ok perfect
and we also have full documentation here
so in case you're looking at something
and you forget oh how did that work you
can take a look at that now here let's
try No
so as I mentioned you can create stuff
in cloud you can open it here so let's
try something we just created in the
cloud oh I should have saved the talk
beforehand but you can open something in
the class ok you can save something in
the cloud opening the player try it out
but what if you don't want to create
content I've done that sometimes I just
want something to try out I don't want
to create something new and that's where
we're adding a new function which gives
you access to all level from
demonstrations in your player app tada
so you can go through look at anything
you want so for example if you want to
learn how five your manual transmission
works I don't know how to drive a manual
car but sure I can learn this ok so it's
working here let's put it in the first
gear you can see it speeding up its
faster or you can put it in neutral
nothing happens you're just stuck where
you started and just to make sure I
demonstrate it's actually quite powerful
so let's take a look at example here
graphics are expensive to draw and if
you can draw this I'm pretty sure you
can throw anything at player asterisks
and that will work for the most part
there might be some edge cases as always
so now you have learned about three apps
which represent three different steps
but like how do you put together so I
went back to my college example of like
when I learned on calculus three and how
are you how I wish I had all these apps
so my typical workflow would have been
to start here I don't know how to do a
crazy in the room let's do integrate 1
over X I know this is not crazy this is
pretty easy so ok this is what the plot
looks like try it out oh I don't know
how to actually do it so let's get the
whole step suffered oh yeah and if you
misspelled it it knows how to do it I
don't know how to spell very well so
it's perfect for me either
you click on the step by step solution
and it will show you how to get there
after that you can open the cloud app
and let's do a cloud in the girl
sometimes the integrals are really hard
and they take a lot of time so I've
chosen an example which we have taken me
a couple of months to probably do when I
was just learning how to do it
paste urine and cloud solve that for you
yeah this would have taken a long time
to do by hand now let's go ahead and
save this notebook renaming it time
saved is what I'm going to call this and
now let's go to player let's video cloud
files
and open the new book so all these three
steps put together you can really learn
something new oh all you can learn
something you you can also play games
just don't tell your professors you're
doing this I'm not responsible for what
happens afterwards now there's a little
Tetris you can rotate yeah I definitely
wish I had this when I was in school
this web turned out very well for some
not so pleasant lectures and also we
also have games in the demonstrations
browser so I recommend you to go looking
for them so going back so well from
cloud and player are available on clouds
available on Android and iOS and pears
available on iOS and as I mentioned
these three apps represent different
steps of the learning process and that's
how I've used them over the years now
and I hope you get to use them too
thank you for listening to me today talk
about three or four apps and how they
can help you with their learning process
I hope you try them all and just
remember learning does not have to be
tied to a desktop anymore you can learn
anywhere you want and feel free to reach
out to me if you have any suggestions
feedback or any bugs you want to report
thank you
you